hey everybody is Jessie and today we
have some pool requests to go over and
[Music]
have to make a decision for sure this
time of weather we're gonna use the beta
material UI or not I know you're
probably tired of even thinking about
this question at this point also I today
has been today and last night have been
really really frustrating so since my my
whole purpose for doing this at least at
first was to give people a realistic
view of what my job as a front-end
developers like I'm gonna briefly
explain what what the day has been like
just to give you a more accurate picture
so as you know I'm working on the
udacity react nanodegree so I am I keep
submitting my project and the way it
works in Udacity is you submit your
project and then they do a code review
and then they send you feedback on your
code and let you know if it's if it's
working properly or not so it it hasn't
been working properly and the first you
know two times I submitted him okay you
know that's legitimate it's some good
feedback should have tested it more but
then last night I I thought I had it I
thought I had had gotten it and so I I
was frustrated so I stayed up late last
night I worked on it and then I thought
for sure I have it the Sun I woke up
this morning and I still didn't fix what
I need
I think some of it but there was still
you know one thing that I didn't test
and it didn't work so that is just super
frustrating especially because I'm so
tired today since I stayed up late to do
that but anyway that's not that's not
even the worst part
so I get to work I started doing my work
it gets right around time when I have a
meeting right before my lunch break so
instead of going to the meeting I just
kind of remoted in right from my office
so there was like a screen share thing
set up so I remote it in late because I
had just gotten an email from a client
that their site was down which was
really worrying because I set up that
site in a similar way to what we did
this this catechetical Institute site
the last time so I checked it out and it
turns out they had like a spike in in
traffic and the database just shut down
on the server that was running WordPress
so I couldn't figure it out couldn't get
it up and running spent my entire lunch
break that I was going to spend working
on Udacity on that luckily I still had
the development version of that
WordPress install on a different server
so one one that I pay for not the
company so I just pointed the subdomain
to that server so that the site is now
back up and it buys me time to figure
out what happened with that so I'm I'm
really interested in what happened
because I don't want it to happen to any
of the other sites that I built like
that so on top of that I get an email
from somebody who's been continually
insisting that a site that I had built
an internal site for for the university
I work for they couldn't access it so it
is you have to login to the site and I
can't I've been trying to actually go to
see this person at their computer and
they've never give me a time when I
could go to see them they've had other
people from the IT department go there
who of course haven't been able to fix
it because they're not developers and
the problem is likely you know maybe
some type of error I don't know I don't
really know what the problem is so I get
another email from this person saying
they try to login and it didn't work so
I checked my error logs I'm not 100%
sure yet I'll give you an update on this
one I know for sure but this is what I
saw when I checked my error logs around
the same time that I got the email about
the error I got this error log and just
I just want to zoom in on this part so
in case that's not immediately sinking
in whoever got this this error was using
Internet Explorer 9 to try to view my
site now I don't I don't know about you
if you all support Internet Explorer 9
in your projects but I make no attempt
to support Internet Explorer 9 and so
that was just if it turns out that this
was in fact the error message from the
person who was trying to log in I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be somewhat relieved
and really annoyed at the same time not
at this person at all I mean certainly
you know I think most people probably
don't even realize what version of a
browser they're using but I will be
super annoyed that for months now I've
been trying to figure out this problem
and it's potentially not even really my
fault it's it's just the fact that it's
you know it's Internet Explorer 9 so
anyway that's been my day so far but
then after all that happened my wife
brought me pizza which was cool and I
got to see the baby for a few minutes
and she was being really cute so so
anyways so that brings me to right now
and
I'm gonna show you the the pull request
that I got and we have some cause for
celebration today and I'll show you in a
minute
yeah Sebastian says in the live chat
Pizza fixes everything so yeah it was it
was good as you know I frequently just
work and don't eat all day so it is
really nice when I actually eat feel a
lot better usually towards the end of
the stream I'm just exhausted and hungry
but today I will not be alright so let
me let me show you I was just trying to
think if I forgot anything I don't think
so
alright let me show you this pull
request that I just merged into the
material UI betta branch so this is from
Rohit and sorry if I'm mispronouncing
the name but I just wanted to especially
show you this because this is his first
pull request that's been accepted so you
could check it out this was the first
pull request and does it show up to the
X that I accepted it
I don't know but anyway I think I think
that this is the first pull request that
that he's had submitted that's been
accepted so that's really cool so
congratulations so basically what what
he's managed to do is to get this site
so obviously it's not perfect like
there's still some weird things going on
probably based on the mark-up that I had
but the the point of the pull request
was to fix those errors so this is no
longer showing any errors all right I'd
still need to get this working in terms
of the side nav and you know fixing this
positioning and things but yesterday we
worked and worked and we couldn't even
get to a point where we could even see
anything except an error message so this
is awesome so this actually makes it
more of a possibility that we could use
the beta I'm I still kind of don't want
to after yesterday because that was a
lot of work so if I run into similar
issues I I don't really want it to slow
me up I'm already I'm I actually
expected to be a lot farther along at
this point than I am so anyway so I went
ahead and merged it into that that
material you I beta branch just so that
it's there because you know maybe in a
few days we realized that the other
version of material UI is just going to
be too hard to work with what we want to
do and I want to try it again or maybe
down the road you know if I I go to redo
this again maybe I'll want to use
material UI beta I mean who knows but I
thought it was worth it to have a on
this branch a version that didn't throw
errors immediately I never really liked
the idea of pushing to get hub a branch
that didn't work so thanks again roulade
for that for that pull request and
he actually submitted to pull requests
so the first one was a theme fix but at
least for me it through an error and I
think the only thing was it was just it
had a lot of stuff from the master
branch that it wasn't the beta so it
just wasn't working right and then you
know almost immediately after I made
some comments on the first pull request
he came back with this with a second one
so that was really awesome oh hey cool
really it's in the live chat so and says
thank you so much for accepting the pool
request you're welcome thank you for
submitting that I'm actually I'm really
I'm excited for two things one that you
submitted the pool question was awesome
also that it's your first pour across I
think it's really cool that I got to to
accept that like that that's a big deal
to me all right so I'm gonna check the
live chat quickly just to say hi to
everyone all right so if you are if
you're new welcome and thanks for
watching so this this show in case you
haven't watched before is me doing my
normal everyday work so there will be
mistakes and some days it seems like
it's all mistakes but we usually manage
to work through the problems eventually
and build some cool things so I'm gonna
try to keep up with the live chat and
every so often I'm gonna check back in
so if you ask a question I don't get to
it right away please don't don't be
upset by that I will get to it and if
you can't stick around I'll still try to
answer it you can watch the recording
later and get the answer so basically if
you haven't seen the other streams for
this project we're building a react
project we use create react app to build
it you know start it and then we're
using material UI which is a material
design framework for
or for building the layout in react apps
so this is my first time using the tear
UI so we're still we're kind of learning
as we go
also there's two other ways to
participate in this stream today so of
course I have the Instagram feed that is
showing my face
whenever I'm whenever I'm doing this and
I have a cool you can barely see in the
background but today I turned on my
little plasma ball a USB flash my ball
so I guess if it was darker you could
see it more but anyway it's cool my kids
always like to play with it when they
come to my office so if you are already
watching on Instagram and you don't
realize that you can see the code on
youtube check out free code cancer
YouTube channel and then there's a third
way so I mentioned that I had n Drock
working so let me give you the link and
you should be able to see the site as I
am developing it so I'm gonna paste this
link in the live chat but if you're not
in the live chat or you're watching this
later on which I'll probably keep and
rock on so there's a chance if you're
watching it a little bit later on today
you can still see the site but it won't
be on all the time so if you are
watching it later and it doesn't work
then my computer's off or something but
otherwise you know you might have a shot
if you're watching maybe an hour or two
after so here's the link in the live
chat Blake asks about the Instagram feed
it's there should be a link in the
description to this video my Instagram
name I think is Jessie dot Weigel so
cool I can see that you all are actually
trying to view this so that's awesome so
if you remember we tried to do this
maybe
month ago maybe more and it just
immediately like shut down because we
hit the limit on the amount of requests
so I explained a few days ago I think
that the person who does end ruk and I
think his name's Alan let me double
check I want to give this guy credit
because I really appreciate it so I'm
I'm actually gonna check my my email
right now to make sure that I get his
name right and I'll probably put
something on Twitter to thanking him
since that's how he first reached out to
me I think it was Outland yeah so Alan
Shrieve who is I don't know if he's I
don't know exactly what he is with n
Grunk if he made it if he's in charge of
of maintaining it I'm not sure but
anyway he basically just hooked us up
saying you know that this will work so I
don't know what he said the Linnet too
but it looks like it's working fine
I haven't normally I would have gotten a
message to say it said it crashed ok so
right now we got a lot of connections
and it seems to be working so so that's
that's awesome
so now I'll run this you know whenever
pretty much anytime I stream and you all
can just immediately see the feedback of
what's going on so that should really
help you know you got you can open up
dev tools now and see the same errors
and inspect things and you won't have to
just see what's on my screen so
hopefully that'll make this way more
interactive I mean there's already a lot
of interaction in the live chat and
that's awesome but I think this was this
was a really really good idea I think it
was Fabian's idea a while back so Fabian
hesitant I don't think he's been able to
join in in the live chat for a while I
haven't seen him I might have seen him
last week or something but
so he's probably not watching now but if
he does watch this thank you for this
idea it was for really awesome all right
so enough of all the the introductory
stuff I'm gonna switch for now I think
I'm gonna switch back to the master
branch so like I said earlier I'm I just
I don't want to do anything with the
beta right now so it was really I don't
know it was really like a little bit
frustrating yesterday when I tried to
work on it and we just couldn't get it
working so I don't want to repeat of
that so I'm gonna switch back to the
master branch let me do this on the
screen so I can see this so so if you're
not that familiar with git you want to
switch branches you do get check out and
then you do the name of the branch okay
so now I've switched to the master
branch and I want to make sure cuz I
don't think I've done pushed anything up
oops get pull not masterful oh all right
so get pool so it's always fresh
whenever you start out it you always
want to do a get pool just in case even
if you're the only person working on it
it's possible that you might have pushed
something from another computer and you
just forgot that's actually happened to
me that's happened to me during the
livestream now because I frequently work
on a laptop when I'm not in my office so
let me move this out of here and let's
see
run yarn just make sure the package is
so different packages switching back and
forth between branches and let me
restart this server as well so it's it's
showing an error right now that's why
I'm doing all this so that should fix it
alright so here we go
we're back to this we have this little
highlight here working thanks to
Sebastian's pull request everything
that's showing up here is a different
component so you know as it should be in
react you know all these little pieces
that you see are all separate components
so you know this app bar is separate and
then we the side nav is is all separate
and then this section here is totally
separate so that's the way we want it so
now I think we ought to build out the
the home view so why not why not start
there that's the first page everyone
will see so we'll start right there and
I guess we could change the title to
that's the only other like really
obvious thing that we could change is
it's obviously not going to be title so
let's yeah let's change that I want to
start out with a win I know if I change
that it won't cause an error and that'll
be one one thing that we can say even if
everything else fails at least we get
that done so where am I
I know this is sad enough now that
everything is in components I'm not sure
where it if where the title is an app
all right app are there we go I'm pretty
sure I made this component so maybe I
did maybe that's why I didn't realize
maybe this isn't one Sebastian made oh
wait a second it should not be like this
I think it's is it holding on I'm going
to close out a bunch of this stuff
occasionally when I check out and switch
from a branch the code editor doesn't
immediately switch everything over and
it holds on to the to the old markup so
in particular for that one it was still
showing the code that we weren't even
using anymore at all so let's try I
think it's sad enough yep that's it so
it's inside enough this this makes more
sense this is how it should look
alright so let's change it to resource
center and I think Sebastian also
submitted a poor request but he
basically said in the the comments for
the for his request that it would
probably just be better to go with a
stable version so that's why I didn't
even I didn't I didn't pull it in but I
think he actually did change the title
least I thought he did I don't maybe
maybe he didn't I don't know now that I
look at it on my other screen I don't
see that so I don't know where I'm
getting that from all right so let's
check it out it's this resource center
awesome ok
so since we don't have column classes
built-in to the the material UI the
version of material you I that we're
using I I kind of think we should I
think we ought to use some of the stuff
from materialized because already
familiar with that so here's what I'm
thinking that we could use assuming that
there's not a lot of conflicts between
class names which we'll have to double
check that we may be able to just blend
these two not use any of the any of the
jQuery related stuff for JavaScript
related stuff at all from materialized
but basically just take their column
classes and use that so if there's any
objections to that let me know I just
would rather not have to build out a
column class system if I don't have to
like from scratch because I already know
how much the materialized system works
I'm really familiar with it
now I just checked back in the live chat
and I see Sebastian saying please change
the active color Patrick Gass please
tell me that bright yellow is a
placeholder yeah yeah the brainy the
bright yellow is definitely a
placeholder tor
I don't know if it's supposed to be tor
tor aI don't know but says maybe you
should create two folders component in
container to store your code yeah
actually I had I had created a component
folder when I was trying to get the beta
to work and so I obviously that that
didn't happen so I do I am going to
create a folder to hold the components
and organize this a little bit better so
like I said I had done it once and then
broke everything so that got thrown out
when I threw out all the things that
broke
all right I was just checking the live
chat there so sorry about the little
silent time
oh cool patrick said I love that hot
reloading is even working over an Gras
yeah I didn't I I figured it would work
I wasn't really sure what to expect but
so far this seems like really really
useful all right so it seems like no one
wants this bright yellow there so let's
change that so I guess we're in the apt
CSS yep alright so we don't want that to
be yellow let's check out the material
design documentation and see what it's
supposed to be
I could never I'm on the site often but
I don't know why the URL doesn't come up
when I type it in okay so that's C cool
this is what I wanted I just wanted to
get this the material design
documentation seems to actually use the
material design spec which is as it
should be I suppose so I'm not even
really gonna look this up I'm just going
to inspect it and see what color they
use that will be faster
why is this much
okay when I I have it on on the other
screen I had taken it took the focus off
so I couldn't see but this is pretty
easy he's just using it's gray let's see
how that looks cool all right much much
nicer to look at and it's actually a
different gray than what we see when we
hover so does that bother anybody that
gray is different I mean should it be
different since the different thing is
happening or should we try to make it
the same I don't really care at this
point I can always change that later on
but let me know what you think if you if
you have a preference okay cool so get
the important things taken care of a
title and we have a new color for the
active link so let's let's commit that
so we have one working commit so let's
check our status and see we've edited
the app CSS file and the side nav JSS
file and I want to commit both of these
at the same time with a commit message
and we're gonna add them as well so to
do that we're going to type git commit
and then we're gonna give it the flag am
so a is going to add it and an means
we're going to put a message right after
that so within quotation marks and you
could do double or single quotes we're
gonna put our commit message and we're
gonna say change title
so they're actually different I guess
different ways to do commit messages so
different places have guidelines for how
you do it so right now I'm not really
using any guidelines except that I don't
do anything in the past tense so I don't
ever say change title it's always
changed title so that's pretty much what
what I adhere to I also try to keep them
as short as I possibly can and I usually
don't use punctuation but sometimes I
forget and just put in a punctuation
mark but if you want to use something
that's standard and I mean if you're
just starting out and you want to start
with good habits you can check out
I think Udacity has their own standard
so you can go
I think it's available somewhere on the
site I don't I don't know if the link is
right now but if you check out the
Udacity get you know commit message
standard it's pretty straightforward if
you're taking Udacity course they want
you to stick to it and I'm sure there
are other companies that have their own
standards so I would actually recommend
doing that so your commit messages are
more uniform because mine are are not
they're all over the place at some point
I'll probably have set a standard for
everybody in my department to use and
potentially like everybody who
contributes to any of the projects but
for right now there is no standard and
let's push this
so we've committed this so this is only
on our local machine if we want this to
be to be reflected in github we got to
push it so we do a git push origin
master since we're on the master branch
and now this change is reflected in
github which is awesome because you know
if the power goes out this computer
shuts down we could just turn on our
laptop and running a Wi-Fi from our
phone and get on github and keep working
I've actually done that before is that
ever happen to you all
I gotta keep my laptop here and so the
Power has gone out and shut the computer
down so I just opened my laptop and keep
going alright so Zach says it's
different and he gives he gave me the
hex code for the color that's the real
color so alright so because you you are
nice enough to give me the color I'll
change it right now so that we have the
same color let's check it out now
there's a networking
oops did I mess it up wait a second
that is not that's not the color that is
blue
cool Nathaniel says back when I lived in
Snowden land Elizabeth City power
outages were a more common thing so I
used mobile tethering in my laptop Zack
says sorry wasn't the color just my
favorite one that was a good color I
mean I like that color it's just not in
the color palette that I can use for
university projects actually if you
don't mind I think I may try that color
out on my my project for Udacity because
I'm I wanted to use a blue color I
picked a different shade but I really
like that shade so maybe I'll maybe I'll
use it I don't want to steal your color
though cuz you you you put it in the
chat first so I think you have dibs on
it for a while at least alright so now
let's let's start with some of these
classes I guess the first thing I want
to do is I just want to look and this is
just on my other screen briefly at some
of the class names that are coming out
just to see about conflicts
so let's look I have the material UI
documentation here as well so see
actually let me close that I had to do a
performance management self-assessment
so I think I have a meeting on Friday
actually I should let you all know
Friday I'm gonna have to stream at a
different time and tomorrow I will so
tomorrow at a normal time I'll be
finishing up a technical interview with
the candidate for web developer job so
I'll probably just bump it ahead to like
2:30 so it won't be a big change but
Friday everyone here gets to leave at
noon which is awesome so I will be here
at the normal time so maybe I'll do it
I'll have to do it
the early because I have my performance
review at I think 11:30 somewhere around
there so I'll let you all know about the
difference but I just want to give you a
heads up so that you're not you know
surprised if I'm not on during my normal
time all right so I want to check I want
to check some of this stuff out so once
again I'm assuming maybe wrongly that
this site is using material UI so we
inspected it before and we thought
figured out that they weren't actually
using it for some parts of it actually
now that I look at the code I'm not I'm
not sure that they're using it at all
let me I'm just I have dev tools open on
my other screen so if you if you want to
check it out you can you know just open
dev so you'll be seeing what I'm saying
but
[Music]
not really sure so maybe I can't do okay
in any case let's just grab what I'd
like to do is actually make make
components to do what we want him to do
so I don't want to just throw CSS in
there so that's what we did for the last
project and that was okay for the last
project because we needed to get a lot
done in a short amount of time for this
project there's not quite as much that
needs to get done so we already have
basically the site that it doesn't
really need to change we just need to
turn it from the jumbled mess of jQuery
that it is into a react site but we can
basically keep most of the Styles the
same so we won't have to worry about
that it's it's basically just me working
on it this is my project the way the
layout is right now was already approved
by everybody that it needs to be
approved by so I don't have to keep
going back and forth to do revisions so
because of all that I think that we can
take the time now to do this in a more
proper way and actually create
components that will work and that we
can reuse and bring forward in our
future projects so that's what I'd like
to do okay I just I just noticed here
down at the bottom of the live chat one
says Jesse I would suggest maybe you can
work each feature in a branch too so get
usage to actually that's that's a really
good idea I think I'm gonna do that so
yeah actually I do like I have people of
all skill levels that watch this so I'm
sure there's a decent number of people
that don't use git yet or just really
new it gets oh that's a great idea
so we'll get used to making branches and
merging and things that'll be that'll be
cool I will I will do that
Tiffany asks which course or courses are
you taking with you dasa T hey Tiffany
I'm pretty sure that I haven't seen you
in live chat before so thank you thank
or for watching and joining in I am
taking the reacts nanodegree right now
I've also done a lot of the front-end
courses but just the the free versions
so I will say this about the paid
version the I normally go for the free
versions of everything but in this case
with the paid version since you get to
keep submitting your projects and get
feedback I'm I'm like forced to learn a
lot more than I normally would so I
think in it can be worth it so if you
don't have somebody else to look at your
code then the paid version is really
really nice because like I said I I
thought my app was working like for
revisions ago like for code reviews ago
and it wasn't so if I had just been
doing a free verse they don't have a
free version of the react nanodegree yet
but if if they had one available and
I've been doing that I would have just
moved on and assume that my app worked
but now I'm being forced to learn the
right way to do it and it's not just the
feedback that I get is not always just
this is wrong do it right some of it is
just suggestions like this is right but
if you want to make it even better you
could do it this way so that's really
really helpful so I think I had said I
would give you all updates on how it's
going so that's probably so far the
biggest takeaway that I have is that I
had no experience with code reviews
before and I really like them I mean
it's frustrating when you get it back
and you've done it wrong but I learn a
lot from it so so anyway that's that's
my experience thus far I'll give you an
update something else Athens
alright let's see I had some some
comments about the colors here okay so
it's Joseph says looks like the darker
color and lighter one okay so let me
cool Zack said I can use his color in my
my Udacity project so awesome I'll do
that 81 was your football number cool so
you're a receiver that's usually your
receiver number my number was 14
alright so I think I'd like to grab the
lighter color
all right cool
Zach says wide receiver kicker and
ponder cool I was right wide receiver
yeah uh once you get up into the 80s
that's receiver yeah I was a quarterback
and outside linebacker all right so let
me switch actually is what I really want
to do is I want to use the lighter color
for everything so I don't want to change
that active color I want to change the
highlight color have to figure out where
that's at where's my where's my menu
item
all right so I think it talks about the
menu items at the bottom of this area
override styles
actually I'm not sure if I can I'm
assuming that this is on hover so I I
don't think I can override it here
because that would be an inline style
you can't do hover stuff on inline
styles right I'm pretty sure you can't
do it let me double check this that it
is in fact a hover is it not
I think I'm on the wrong
this is interesting so let me show you
what's going on here whoa let's do the
holy city said alright so I'm going
through here and trying to add the hover
so like over here I'm just going and
clicking hover and dev tools and none of
these are actually making a change this
maybe is this one
no what else could I even put this one
okay so everything here alright so let's
see so it's actually so it's actually
not a CSS hover effect which is that's
interesting I will I just assumed it was
so it's acts it's a let me see what
changes
huh
all right so it looks like the only
thing that's changing is just that the
background color does change so that's
really interesting
all right
so I guess we can I I really wanted to
use like the the actual you know props
here
but I guess I could just put it in the
CSS file
it is
all right so I guess we'll just change
this
actually I am gonna have to I am gonna
figure out have to figure out how to
change this because it's it's not
he's actually changing the color like
this background color seems like it's
part of the state let's check out that
component for a minute
actually forget it this is a side check
this would be something to do later on I
don't want to get sad jacked with this
probably just because I'm really tired
it was easy for me to get sidetracked
that's an unimportant thing right now
that can go in the list of things to do
later on I can I can live with it being
a different color just for now and I
could always just change it change this
to be the same color and that'll be a
lot easier so let's grab some of the
material
[Music]
that's scarier I was hoping that the
github would be in my my drop down there
but it wasn't okay so let's go to
it's a lot easier actually to go to the
SAS and see what grid see what we need
actually now that I think about it the
problem had before is that it's really
hard to just pull part of this since it
depends on a lot of variables and other
files so I think I will just go to the
CSS then if you're not familiar with
sass
it's a whoops wrong spot if you're not
familiar with sass oops
it is a CSS preprocessor so you can do
more than you can do with normal CSS you
can have like variables and some logic
in there and you can combine like
separate files together and so it's
really cool but I wanted I want to see
this file this the CSS is what gets
produced when you you know compile it
all to normal CSS so what I'm gonna do
is I know call us the column is what I
want
I never eyes there's so many thing with
call in it oh my goodness there we go
that's to search for a row so I want
these container classes and everything
and actually before I do this let me
I just want to check
I want to check I don't really know that
much about licenses so I want to make
sure that I give attribution properly or
if I'm even allowed to pull out part of
this okay its MIT license I know enough
to know the MIT license is pretty pretty
open let me see if they actually have a
license there you go
okay so basically it seems like I can do
whatever I want and use this as long as
I keep this
this license with it which I don't
really see any reason why I couldn't
have an MIT license on my project as
well if anyone had knows of any good
reasons why I shouldn't then let me know
now but that's not really a big deal I
don't really care if anybody uses any of
my stuff okay cool so let's let's do
that then
let's put a license on our project and
then we'll grab this and we should be
good and let me know if someone knows
more about licenses and I'm making a
mistake here let me know please in the
live chat
obviously Sebastian said might be using
jsm else over to change background color
yeah that's what I think I think it's
probably using that that's what I was
gonna look at the component to see
before I realized that that was just
kind of a waste of time
because I had better things to do all
right so let's I want to do this license
thing first because otherwise I'll
probably just put it off and never do it
and I think it'd be cool to show you all
how to do this so there's a really easy
way to do a license within github so I
mean obviously we could just copy and
paste that which would be really easy
but I'd like to show you this in case
you want to use a different license
where's my site Resource Center right
yeah okay so if we go in here and go to
create new file and then type in
:
he's got a I see yet no I can't i spell
license hey I seriously spelled license
correctly last night license right no
with all right somebody help me out what
is wrong with me li si en se right right
yeah all right what's supposed to happen
maybe I have to put in caps
what's supposed to happen is that
there's something supposed to come up on
this side that'll let you just pick a
license why this has worked last night
for me my eyes are not working right now
dear refresh this page
there we go okay this is what's supposed
to happen if you manage site license
correctly the first time you can choose
a license template right so you click
this and you can go in here and pick a
license and it'll tell you all kinds of
things about that license so you can go
through and pick which one you need so
that's what I really wanted to show you
because this is pretty cool if you're
not sure about it you can go to learn
more but this can help you if if you're
not exactly sure about your license so
I'm gonna pick the MIT license see it
already fills in everything for me it
even fills in the year and the name in
this case it's the name of the
organization otherwise like on my on my
own github it puts in my name so you
know I should I want to see full name of
copyright owner I'm gonna put my name
because so technically when I started
working here I signed no contract so I
pretty much control the code that I
write so that there's nothing there's
nothing that says that my code like that
I can't use elsewhere so I'm gonna
interpret that as I can use it however I
want and other projects and so let's go
to review and submit so you can check it
out here it is and we have a license
file and I wanted that's V dot MD cool
awesome and then right from here we can
we can if we wanted to create a new
branch for this commit and then start a
pull request actually let's do that
since like one said it would be cool to
get more practice with git so let's
start a new branch for a pull request
and then we'll merge this request in and
since I already know what's happening
here like will do it through the github
interface and then in the future we'll
do them through the command line
cool so now we're gonna open a pull
request create license I don't think I
really need to write anything that's we
know what that means and you can see it
shows the changes we've created a new
file so really easy to tell what's going
on and let's create the pull request now
I can see this pull request this pull
request number seven and let's merge it
and there's they're actually options so
we can merge the pull request and
there'll be a merge commit and so this
just says exactly what's happening and
I'm gonna confirm the merge and then now
if we go back to our local machine we
can run a get pool and we have our
license
all right so cool successful thing
number two that we've done today all
right so now I saw something Sebastian
said material.you I actually does have a
grid system so Sebastian material oh I
just want to let you all know the the
live the live stream from Instagram has
ended so that oh that has a one hour
time limit so if you want to check it
out the videos available for 24 hours
after I recorded so Sebastian if there
is a great system I know I couldn't find
one before I found one with the beta
version but I couldn't find a grid
system with the old version so am I just
am I missing something or is it just
with the beta also Sebastian found out
how to edit that that color add this to
the list item hover color Alexander says
hey from Russia love your coding
sessions Jessie thanks and thanks for
watching I really appreciate it okay
Sebastian is saying grid list
I checked out grid list a few days ago
and I it wasn't what I wanted I mean
maybe it would get the job done but it
was not what I really had in mind with
with the grid system let's see what was
I gonna I was gonna change the
the hover color
so I'm assuming that on here I can
change the hover color Wow
I don't think that you saw that but if
you you ever had your hands like one key
off I just I had them one key off and
then it just messes up everything
yes like I guess see Joseph said as well
I could put it in a theme but I'm not
really gonna use these the same way
anywhere else so I think I'll just do it
like this for now assuming that this
will work and what was the color we were
using let's see if that works
not yet No
okay so Joseph said menu item won't work
because it doesn't pass the prop okay so
I will need to then put this in our
theme are we even using a theme yeah we
made this right this is a few esteem
okay Sebastian said added to the list
item not the menu item
actually I'm not
yeah okay Joseph that's what I was just
thinking I can't put it on the list item
because it's generated by menu items so
anyway I'm just I'll figure that out at
a different time I really want to move
over this this code from materialized to
where did I have okay so let's try to
grab everything we need should basically
all the column classes and it'll
probably be obvious pretty early on
whether or not they're conflicts as far
as the class names go
if that happens we'll figure out what to
do but maybe it won't happen okay
oh that's cool they actually have an
Excel class built-in I remember for a
project I made my own Excel classes you
used to have it was just small medium
and large so I should have submitted a
pull request for that I could have got
this in oh well I just didn't have time
at the time to really clean it up and
submit so all right so now we have all
that let's let's pull in
all right so would it make I think it
would make sense to have a Styles folder
so let's do that so from the command
line we can create folders by doing make
directory and we can do so you want this
to be within source and let's call it
styles so now we have that directory and
now we want to create a new file so
we're going to use the command touch
source styles and we'll call this
materialize grid and that's a CSS file
okay so now we have the Styles folder
and we have this materialize grid and
then we can put all of our grid styles
in here all right so everything's in
here and we'll save that and then we can
pull that in oops I meant meant to get
the app j/s so we can pull that in here
in our app das and importer here and
then it'll be available for us to use
for for all of our stuff so if we could
see here we already have an import of a
CSS file so let's just copy that and
then import the column classes here and
so what we want is to go into the Styles
folder and then
materialise grid okay let's check it out
all right so so far nothing weird has
happened now we should be able to use
the materialized classes so let's go
into our home view I'll switch it back
up let's go into our home view and try
to try to use some of them I just
remembered I forgot to use my Pomodoro
clock again this is two days in a row so
I don't think I'm gonna use it now it's
in something this far in whereas okay we
have views and home
okay so within our home view I want this
all to the inside of a container
and then within that container we're
gonna have a a row and then within the
row of columns and we'll do s 12 medium
4 and that should give us our 3
okay and actually we don't need that
anymore we have two missing one Dave
okay so we have this and let's just put
depending on what the fonts doing with
material you I may we may want to bring
in that that flow text responsive font
class from materialized as well because
I kind of like that and it would match a
lot of what we're doing with other sites
so let's just make loose nice one three
okay
and save it and see what we have
what did I do
all right so obviously I didn't really
have an error in index so where's my ear
probably in home since that's the only
thing we change let me see what have I
done
there we go
9:7 no i'm jazz
all right good call Alexander thank you
and who else
tor tor yeah yeah says try return
awesome
so all right cool check that out so we
have our common classes and see if this
works when we go small yes great this
don't actually look centered though
what's going on let me move this over so
we can see this okay I see why it
doesn't look centered because these are
just right aligned so that's fine so
this is actually the only one so this is
our container which is full width with
margins and the margins actually get
smaller their bet percentage based but
even the percentages themselves change
there with the media queries so that's
cool on small screens the margins are
really small which is what we want this
is our row this is our columns these are
columns cool
so that is working as we want let's
throw some cards in here but let's use
the material UI cards and then that'll
be a kind of even better test of
conflicts when we start intermixing more
of the components from material UI you
see I don't really like that font wait
it's a 400 wait I think I like 300 yeah
I like 300 better anyway I'll change
that later I don't wanna get that
checked
alright let's throw in some cards so
let's go back to our material UI
documentation here and let's look up the
cards let's make this a bit bigger so
you want a card and we just want just
wanted a really plain card let's see
it joins the most plain none of it they
don't you know have just a regular
playing card alright so I just have to
grab this and then take stuff out
let's grab this card
and probably I'll take out almost all of
that stuff so I don't want the actions
take out the card actions and don't want
a title yeah I think I might want the
title right now I think do I have
explanatory text I do I think I have a
title text and then instead of an image
I have an icon so let's leave the card
media maybe not I don't think I don't
know I think I want to leave the card
media how does this look
yeah I don't really want it to appear
like a separate section so let's take
this out for now it'll just make it
easier and I don't want the header okay
so now we have a much more basic card
which should be good for for our
purposes
let's pop these cards in here and then
we need to import some things so let's
import all this stuff and we can get rid
of the stuff or not using once we pull
it in so we don't need the card actions
the card header or the card media
okay save that see how it looks cool all
right so we have these cards okay not
bad they need definitely we need to work
on our padding so in in materialize the
cards themselves have the right padding
so it usually doesn't happen like this
so we'll have to just see if I mean
maybe we want them to be closer together
I don't I don't think that doesn't look
I think I'd like to have a little bit
more padding so other than some you know
padding issues this is what we want I
mean obviously we wanted to come down a
bit
we'll probably vertically align so we
might actually grab the vertical
alignment classes as well from
materialise yeah
now what we can do so basically we've
put in the CSS and we've tested it and
it pretty much does what we want it to
do what we could do and what we may end
up doing is making components where we
could you know have a component that
would let's say be column and then you
would pass it you know what you wanted
it to be and then that would end up
being these things you know but it would
be in the form of a component and we
could do the same thing with row and
container if we wanted to I'm not sure I
don't know if it would be better to make
these all components or if it would be
better to leave someone like this I kind
of if I had to say I would say the
column is a much better candidate to be
its own component than the row in the
container just because you know the
columns I mean it can change a lot they
would be decent to be able you know pass
props in and change what you want him to
to have it would also be cool you know
to change these based on you know a
change in state so you could switch up
your column so it would then be pretty
easy to do something like I don't know
have a toggle to say you can toggle
between like a grid layout and a
full-width layout you know just by
clicking the button and then all the
button would do would just just do a set
state so that would be cool I the only
place where that might be useful is
maybe where we do the we're gonna do the
image gallery for the logos otherwise I
don't really think we need to use
something like that so I mean currently
we don't have that functionality so we
don't really have to add it in
okay I'm gonna go to the live chat well
first let me let me copy this because
basically this is going to be our layout
so we're just going to do this twice
cool
and I'd like to see
Wow there's a lot of things you can do
with cards cool
okay cool one thing I definitely want to
do with these cards is make sure that
they always stay the same height so
we'll see how I want to do that I've
done it before with some flexbox stuff
which doesn't work it doesn't work well
with the way everything was done in
materialised but it might work better
with this I'm not sure I'll have to look
at the the markup that's created from
the card component or we can do it by a
bunch of media queries setting min
heights which I'd rather not do it that
way all right so I'm gonna check the
live chat really quickly before I commit
this in case there's something I should
I should do differently and then after
that if this is all good I'll commit
this push it up to github and then I'll
be taking some questions so if you were
just here for the code probably not
gonna be too much code left so thanks
for watching if you want to I'm gonna
quit watching now that's cool otherwise
if you have questions put them in the
live chat now worried if you can't stick
around you can put them in the comments
below or direct message me on Twitter
hey Jeremy how's it going so Jeremy has
joined us in the lab chat thanks for
joining us okay looks like there's no
messages related to these cards but but
actually it looks so much better with
content there I don't know about you but
I mean it I mean obviously like this
there needs to be space right there that
looks terrible but actually having
something here makes it look a lot
better I can't that's one weight really
bothers me I'm definitely gonna change
that soon all right so let's oh ed we
were gonna make different branches for
each thing that we're doing right so
let's see I think for now since with the
end I'm just gonna commit this but then
I'm gonna try to think out when I make
my Trello cards I'm gonna try to make it
a point to make each task in my Trello
card a separate branch and then that'll
be cool so we'll know when we move it to
done at that point we will merge the
branch and then we can keep track of
things like that we can also I think
there's a plug-in or an add-on in in
Trello to where you can attach github
issues or pull requests to a Trello card
so we'll try that out - that seems seems
like it would be kind of cool - to do so
anyway for now I'm just gonna do a
straight commit to the master branch
also I had some advice from someone in
the comments for YouTube saying that
they usually have a dev branch they do
everything on the dev branch and they
they leave the master branch basically
at a really basic level and only
it's like periodically to the master
branch so I'm kind of thinking about
doing that so let me know what you think
about that I think I was understanding
what he was saying correctly I was
actually gonna try to do it for this
stream but I totally forgot just because
of everything else that happened today
all right so we're gonna commit and well
first let's go status just to see what
we changed okay cool so we can't do a
regular git commit with the am flag
because it won't add this okay so we
actually need to add this so we could
add it by name but since we're gonna add
all this anyway at the same time let's
um let's do get and then we can put a
period and it'll add everything so now
if we do get status we can see
everything's ready now we can do a git
commit and this time we don't need to
add because we've already added we can
just do the M for the message and we'll
say
[Music]
call them classes actually it's more
than just the column stuff - would you
really call it a greater is it a column
system I don't know I'm not really that
worried about it because I think we all
kind of know what we're talking about
when we say grid system page layout okay
what do you mess up 300k we defined I
forgot to get rid of this so that I
think those were the buttons that were
used in the action items in the card and
we remove that section but we never
remove that button so cool so now let's
just so that commit actually never went
through right it stopped it before that
was committed so we can just press the
UP button on our keyboard and it'll
bring up that same thing and we can just
hit enter again and run it again it
should work this time assuming we didn't
make any other mistakes and it did now
we can do a git push and all right now
it's on github okay so now we're good
and doesn't matter what happens to our
computer everything is on github and now
I'm gonna check out the live chat so let
me scroll up a bit and let's see I want
to try to get everybody's questions if I
happen to not get to your question just
send me you know send me a message and
I'll try to get to it and I know some of
you have sent me stuff so either in the
comments or on Twitter and I've tried to
at least get back to everybody with with
something even if it's like hey I'll
check this out later so I just I've been
really busy lately between my class and
and work and everybody's birthdays this
past weekend so I haven't forgotten
about you I'll try to get to it when I
can
oh now I'm gonna be even more busy with
my my client site like Christ database
crashing but on to my best okay so open
comment says anyone working on Drupal 8
actually no I'm not working on anything
with Drupal 8 now I did briefly try it
out but now I applied to speak at a
drupal conference and talk about how you
can use the drupal api with reacts but i
didn't hear back from them so i don't
know when they closed that but I didn't
get anything so guessing I'm not gonna
get into that conference so if I did get
accepted then I was gonna look up more
about Drupal but basically it's very
similar to using the WordPress API so
that's why I I applied to speak there
Fred says hi I need a job Fred if you're
if you're looking for a job if you um if
you send me a tweet so like if if you're
on Twitter put in a tweet like what kind
of job you want and what your
qualifications are and then tag me in it
and then I'll retweet it and I don't
have a lot of followers but most of the
people that follow me are in you know
the tech industry so they might know
someone or know something so otherwise I
can't really help you about getting a
job not really in a position to give out
hubs at this point but if any of you
watching are get in touch with Fred
Abdi says hi hey how's it going
Nathaniel says I had to leave early
yesterday can you let me know what I
missed I don't think we did I think we
spent most of the second half of the
stream just going over questions so I
don't think I actually coded anything
okay I see a patrick said I wrote
everything back yeah that's that's true
I did I couldn't get it couldn't get the
beta to work
okay when when I was talking about my
github branch and I was glad that I
didn't have Arizona toin said I don't
think it's bad to push a branch with
errors to get hub as long as it is not
master might be fun yeah I can kind of
see that especially if you needed help
with those errors and you're working on
a team of course you would want to push
it so that they could help so yeah I
guess that's not really a big deal now
that I think about it so yeah thanks for
that that kind of made me think about it
differently
Blake said I'm loving these livestreams
awesome I'm glad you're loving this
dreams thanks for watching and
participating in the live chat fred ass
Hades Python in your projects I've never
used Python in a project for a client I
I took the intro to computer science
course from Udacity and they use Python
in that course so I did some Python with
that but honestly I didn't even finish
the course so I didn't do anything
really advanced with Python but I kind
of like Python it was really easy to
work with it was cool like a lot of it
was the syntax was kind of easy to write
Daniel says I thank you for the live
you're welcome
thanks for watching and joining in live
chat
okay Sebastian says there's no need to
add a general theme when using material
UI if I only want to just apply
something to a component because if I
added theme to the root I'd have to add
all the different customizations to the
theme file and I'm assuming that's for
the beta because obviously where we are
using a theme file right now for this
version so but that's good to know if I
use the beta later on if any of you are
planning on using the beta not really a
need to do global theme if you really
don't need to
okay about halfway through the live chat
now
okay so he had some some of you
recommending some themes so skeleton
theme Patrick says get skeleton calm
I've heard about that theme I have not
used it and then harsh it says semantic
UI is also great and it has react
bindings to cool open comments ass is
there react project one day one video
looks like this is react project - and
how many days - project one go to many
days project one went so I for this
project I started doing like the days
because I think that'll be easier for
people who want to watch later on and
it's easier for me so for the first
project I was trying to describe in the
title of the video what I was going to
do now I'm just gonna put that in the
description and not the title the title
is just gonna say what day it is and
what project it is if maybe if I can fit
some little descriptive thing in there I
will but I think that'll be a little bit
more helpful to keep track of everything
because this playlist is going to end up
being huge and have lots of different
projects so I think it'll be better like
this so if you want to go back to
project one day one you have to actually
go to my youtube channel and the links
in the description for this video and
find the video that's called building a
website as fast as I can
and if you start with that one and watch
there I think there's maybe two or three
of those on my channel and then I
started streaming for free code camp and
the rest of them are all in the live
coding with Jesse playlist all in order
there so it's a little bit confusing for
that but hopefully it'll be a much
easier
system of naming from here on out
I see Patrick pretty much said what I
just said thanks pastor
Sebastien says I have some issues with
my PC for some reason opening tabs on
Chrome and Firefox slows down my PC
video and audio are d synced over time
in YouTube don't know what to do
might have to reinstall windows 10 to
see what's causing the issue happens to
a friend too but worse sarah says have
you tried reinstalling Chrome or Firefox
sebastian installed firefox only to see
if it happens
yeah that's uh I had that happen on my
PC but it was a long time ago I don't
know if I ever really found a solution
for that either so I'm not really sure
what was causing it I remember looking
it up but I don't it's been years ago so
I don't really remember what I found out
sorry I can't help you more if I wanted
to be a jerk I would just say like buy a
Mac but I'm not I'm not gonna say this
I'm not like a Mac only guy either I
have pcs and a Chromebook and Linux
servers so they all have their their
pros and cons Sebastian says controversy
that's not football okay yeah so for for
all the non American people and I guess
Canadian because they have football - or
at least american-style football when we
were talking about football we did not
mean what everyone else calls football
that we call soccer so I should say that
Zach and I played American football
that's what they call it right in the
rest of the world I'm pretty sure sorry
I've never been out of the United States
my knowledge of everywhere else is all
secondhand so yes we I did not play
soccer so when I was growing up the
soccer wasn't really a thing where I was
at
so I played American football sorry if I
offended anyone in Europe or or
elsewhere pretty much the rest of the
world is like called soccer football I
think
Oh Emmanuelle said that that son this
was a while ago sorry I didn't see this
in respond to it
Manuel says the codes are blurry so yeah
sorry about that
maybe in terms of my connection it was
it was really good it was over five
thousand kilobits per second the whole
time so it should be okay it's possible
that somewhere between you and I the
connection is slowing down or as Sarah
mentions you could try changing the
video settings sometimes that happens to
me although I try to set it to auto or I
try to set it to be HD all the time it
always reverts to auto on YouTube and so
even when I know I have a good
connection sometimes it'll start me out
at a really low quality and I have to
manually change it although sometimes it
corrects itself oh one says that you
there's choose a license com
so I showed how to do the license
through github but if you would like to
see a different place where you can get
information on licenses you can use
choose a license com I've never been
there so that's not an official
endorsement I'm just saying what once it
MFC 88 thank you for spelling out
license properly for me I think I've
said this before but it's crazy how much
I misspelled when I'm live-streaming and
I normally can spell it fine I mean I'm
not gonna say I'm a great speller
obviously like autocorrect is ruined me
and I don't even bother spelling things
properly anymore but I normally can type
and spell pretty well but not whenever
I'm loud
okay David said you can do the same
thing alright in terms of adding the the
license by going into the insights tab
actually I don't think I've ever done
that let's check it out
inside where can I
okay cool so from the insights tab you
can add alright so we do ever readme we
have a license we have no code of
conduct or guidelines for contributing
so maybe we should add these in a future
stream that would be cool to have this
kind of properly built out especially
since we we are getting contributions so
yeah maybe we'll do that thanks for that
I never realized you could you could
click that and one says there's also an
option to choose a license when you
create the project and github so I
usually just skip that because I'm
always like when I start a project I'm
either not sure what its gonna be for
sure or I'm in a hurry and but that
would probably be a better thing to do
and just be pick the license right off
the bat and not worry about it
Jordan said what would I miss and that
was like at least a half an hour ago so
sorry for not answering then basically
we were just kind of changing the title
and the color of the active page in the
side nav we added a license we copied
over some styles from materialized and
then I think at that point you're
already here so you saw the rest of it
so didn't miss much I went over pool
request to Marvin said that indentation
gave me cancer was it when I think when
I was working on this the indentation
was really crazy so I don't worry about
it anymore because I know it's all gonna
get fixed every time I commit but yeah
sometimes it just looked crazy
that's what's a what's a good CSS
framework besides bootstrap Blake says
get skeleton comm wants his foundation
[Music]
also skeleton evidently does not have a
CDN
I I liked materialised as an alternative
to bootstrap but if you're going to use
react you may not want to go with
materialized because a lot of stuffs
done through jQuery and you don't really
want to manipulate the Dom with jQuery
if you're using react
okay so it looks like some people use
foundation as a framework also Joseph
says I'm trying out semantic UI and my
next project
okay AdMob and says branches this is
we're talking about doing separate
branches branches only really makes
sense if you have to work on different
things parallely is that it's Eduard
Parri lovely I probably would have said
in parallel now I'm probably gonna have
to look that up I want to know if that's
a word and if so I'll start using it
Alexander says Jessie what kara so would
you recommend to use with react to Jas I
don't think I've used so I have used the
materialized carousel with react Jas but
I wouldn't recommend doing that because
as I said you don't usually want to
manipulate the Dom so I'm not sure did I
use I wonder now I wonder if there's
some sort of carousel that comes with
this it doesn't look like it okay yeah I
have no recommendations for react
carousels because I've I've not used one
the proper way at least with with react
so sorry about that if anyone else is
used to carousel with react that's
actually a react component and does
things the proper way then please put it
in the live chat
okay one says I like the master and dead
branches scheme you can use tags for
releases - okay cool
oh I'll try my best to remember that and
and actually get that going for for the
live stream tomorrow Blake asks what do
you guys think about Jekyll Alexander
thinks Jekyll is awesome
Blake says I'm still a noob so should I
wait and see how it works and everything
yeah I have not used Jekyll before but
I've seen videos on it and I think it
looks really interesting and cool so
Alexander says I'm still a new - you can
check dev tips channel here on YouTube
and see how Jekyll works yeah actually I
think I think I've watched the dev tips
videos on Jekyll so I like the dev tips
channel
I think it's Travis does the videos I
think he does a really good job and you
learn a lot and they're fun to watch too
so yeah check that out to learn more
about Jekyll 1 says I work with Drupal 8
right now ok cool so I think we were I'd
gone back and someone asked about Drupal
8 so once it's working with your boy
that's cool we have I'm only if I use a
CMS I normally use WordPress but we do
have some things built some sites that I
don't work on directly but we have some
sites you at the University they're a
bit with Drupal I've worked with it a
little bit in the past
yosef says I just wonder how much you
get paid for a monthly basis I don't
let's see I was about to show you my
timesheet on on air but then I thought
about it and I I thought I better not
just in case like there's some personal
information like uh I don't know what's
on that screen maybe as my social
security number and everything so I'm
gonna do it on my other screen now
because I don't remember what I make in
a month but I will tell you in a few
seconds so I'm actually a big proponent
of not keeping salary information secret
so I think normally that works against
employees and it benefits the employers
more so I think we would all be better
off if salary information were pretty
available the only time that it could
potentially hurt employees if you're
going to get a new job and your
employers realize that you don't make
that much and so they think they can get
away with offering you less other than
that situation I think normally it's
better so let me go to my on my other
screen I'm going to find the information
and then I'll let you know
all right so every month after they take
taxes out and insurance and all that
other stuff that get taken out of my
paycheck I make about twenty five
hundred dollars so I'm not sure if
that's a lot or not a lot in my the my
area of the United States is pretty
economically depressed so that's that's
enough for me to pay all my bills and
support my wife and four children but in
a lot of areas like in big cities that
would that would be nothing that that
might not even cover rent
one says I push to github even if it has
errors just in case you never know maybe
your laptop burns yeah that is that's
another good point Yosef says I really
love your live coding because it keeps
you motivated well awesome I really
appreciate when you all another there
have been some other really positive
comments today in the live chat I really
do appreciate that so I don't get tired
of hearing that said because I mean
honestly like with the streams I there
are good days and bad days there days
when things get really well and then
there are days when I feel like I've
done nothing right so the positive
feedback helps me to want to keep going
it so I actually really do look forward
to the streams right now and everybody's
been like 99% of every comment I've
gotten has been positive so I don't
intend to stop doing these streams
anytime soon unless something beyond my
control happens and I have to suck Oh a
patrick says pure CSS looks good if you
want to include just the functionality
you need okay that's cool
let's see lei Tuan on I'm I'm not he's
actually I pronounced that I'm sorry so
as you can try to use styled component
cool
yeah actually I'm Patrick says I did so
I did use the styled components in my
last project so I actually I liked it I
think that's really useful one says yeah
we do we call it American football in
Spanish okay cool that's what I thought
thought it was American football I
wonder how it came to be that we called
two different sports the same thing I
don't I don't understand I don't know
the history of how that happened
okay Joseph I see just have put in some
some CSS to change the active div so
cool Thank You J Rex asks what
programming language did you use
back-end so this site for the last
project it was one server used
JavaScript use node and then for another
server we use PHP so the content
management system was WordPress on one
server running PHP and then the other
server was react running no Jazz for
this project it's it's going to be
reacting nodejs and then I don't think
we're even going to use a content
management system we'll see I haven't
decided for sure what I want to do
depending on how much time I have for
this I'm like kind of thinking about
maybe either trying out one of the
content management systems that runs on
node or just trying out you know trying
to do a database like maybe like MongoDB
or something like that just working with
it so I'll have to see like how what
other projects are coming up and how
important they are to get done I might
not have time to work with that Emilia's
hi Jesse Texas take a lot from you in
the US but it is definitely a good
salary globally I would say okay cool
yeah I know it's it's pretty it's hard
to compare you know salaries for our
different places actually the best thing
I've ever seen for that is called the
Big Mac index I don't know if you ever
heard about that but it basically just
tells you how much it costs to buy a Big
Mac from McDonald's all over the world
and then like that's that's a the index
you know that's the good measure I guess
so I mean really like economists
actually use that so
than that it is kind of hard to compare
let's see Alpina of CSS says I really
appreciate you doing this could you make
isomorphic app tutorial yeah I I mean
I've said this a lot and I'm sorry I
haven't been able to do it but I really
do want to make some tutorials like
pre-record them and put them on my
channel and I'd like to do a tutorial
using react or next j/s which will allow
you to very easily make an isomorphic
yes or says thank you for your honesty
yeah no problem
like I said I'm I'm pretty open about
salary stuff so and my salary it's not
like it's uh I mean there there are
people to make doing the same thing I do
and make a lot more and I'm sure there
are people doing the same thing that I
do they make less - but I can pay the
bills and support my family so that's
that's really what matters I mean I'm
sure everybody could always say they
wish I had more but you know at the end
of the day you know I have it I have
enough to survive one so and I like what
I do
Emilia says here in Guatemala average
front-end programmer makes you I'm
$1,000 for 40 hours a week okay
cool that's interesting I know there's a
big at least I've read before that
there's a big difference and what
developers get paid in different
countries so like right now in the
United States developers get paid a lot
compared to other jobs but I've heard
that in some countries it's not like
that so you know for whatever reason in
the United States right now they need
more developers so they're willing to
pay a higher higher amount
alright Joseph said I'm changing a Wi-Fi
signup portal from PHP my sequel to
react sequel Lite 3 or react [ __ ]
that's really cool I'd like to see if
that's Joseph if that's a project that
could be made available on github that
would be really cool to see so send me a
link if your your able to put that on
github and I would be really interested
in seeing it AB I know CSS says you are
a really great tutor and I know that
this is time consuming time that you can
spend with your child but it would be
great to get some clarifications in your
style yeah yeah like I said I do really
want to do some more stuff so you know
we'll see how it goes
I actually I mean I don't have nearly
enough subscribers yet to even think
about getting money from YouTube but
maybe one day I can justify like doing
more video right now it's just hard to
justify like go home and say to my wife
like hey I'm gonna take a couple of
hours and make youtube videos and not
get anything out of it
but if I could say like you know hey I I
could potentially get like ad revenue or
something you know then that would be
justifiable you know for me to say like
it's it's almost like a second job and
then then at least I could say you know
I'm providing some more money for my
family and then it might be more doable
for me to produce stuff more regularly
but for right now I'm you know that's
that's like probably a long long way off
if if it ever happens but I will try to
make some tutorials when I can
- CSS is we get $1700 monthly in Croatia
for four years a week okay cool
that is cool I really I'm really
interested in what people get Jarek says
are you working as freelance or in-house
or something yeah I work at a university
so I'm a full-time front-end developer
for for University and then I do some
work on the side like freelance work but
I I don't really like to do a lot unless
it's a project I'm really interested in
or I'll make a lot of money off it
because I'm pretty busy so I'd rather
not take up more of my time than I need
to pop I know CSS says okay you need
wife permission in the frowny face in a
smiley face yeah I mean like basically
because I couldn't if I were to want to
take more time to do that that would
mean that I wouldn't be able to watch
the kids and I would have to ask my wife
to watch all four of our kids and then
she wouldn't have time to do any of the
things that she would like to do you
know normally when I get home from work
I watched the kids right so otherwise
she would have them all day every day
with no breaks so that's what I mean
when I say I'd have to be able to
justify that so if if I went home and
said hey wife why don't you why don't
you watch the kids for another couple
more in a couple of hours you know with
no break so I can just go make youtube
videos right then then that wouldn't
sound as good but if I could say like
hey I'm gonna make a bunch of money off
of ads on YouTube if I put out you know
three or four videos a week then it
might make her a little bit more happy
and she could have so you see I don't
does that make sense that it would just
be I don't know if you're married maybe
you you understand Mike Scioscia kids
like it would be it just seems like to
me
it's it's a lot easier to make the case
for me to do more and in terms of work
if the the payoff is greater so anyway
okay this before yes I do have four kids
yeah so from 8 years old down to 9
months old and I have two girls and two
boys all right so I've gotten to the end
of the live chat and that's about yeah
that's over to our video at this point
but if you have any any other questions
you know feel free to reach out to me on
Twitter okay there's one more question
in there Jay rec says how long have you
been working as a dev at the University
it's been about two years but before
that I was freelance for about three
years I think so all in all about five
years like that I was seriously
developer I mean I I did some websites
here and there before that but I
wouldn't say that I was a serious you
know developer until about like five
five years ago or so and I really well I
wouldn't would not have called myself
like a true developer that first year I
was really just learning a lot Oh
aim highs here yeah sorry you're you're
too late we're about to end so you can
catch the the recording it'll be
available yeah and and give me an update
on how the job is going to you can
message me on on Twitter or something so
I'm interested okay all right so for
real this time
I'm gonna be done so thank you so much
for watching tomorrow the stream is
probably gonna be a little bit later
maybe around 2:30 3 o'clock
and Friday it's going to be really early
so I'll let you know about that time
tomorrow and have a great day I'll see
you all tomorrow